what is the strat you're using right
you're looking for undervalued basically
like sam you said
okay sean and sam about similar twitter
followings but sean's coin is more
expensive right now so i'm gonna buy a
ton of sam
and also they're in the same vehicle of
my first million so like
you know you know there's a good chance
they'll they'll grow together so you saw
sam as an undervalued asset
is that the core thing you're doing
basically just looking for the
undervalued
so so there's two main investment
strategies and then there's multiple
investment strategies under the second
one so the first one is you just buy big
cloud and you just bet on the whole
platform
and i'm probably going to keep like 60
of my money just in big cloud
and then once you own big cloud you can
buy and buy
creator coins right creator coins are
like the sam coin the sean
coin within that strategy i have a few
strategies so one is
i buy undervalued people like the sampar
who until yesterday was valued at zero
and i and i bet that he's gonna go up
right
and then there's people i've also bought
some elon musk and some chamath and some
of the people who are already trading at
really high numbers
because i just think it's the plot
they're blue chippers people are going
to go to the to the face
the fang of bitcoin basically right
that's like buying like you know it's
like buying like yeah like walmart you
know i was buying like you know chemical
or neva
um so and then i'm looking like i'm
telling you chuck norris you watch chuck
norris is gonna
go out like
austin reef at morning brew i think he's
gonna go way up
and he's gonna do better than sam
because sam's kind of being a wuss about
big clown from what i can tell
i i think it's true i am being a little
bit of a wuss i just can't tell if i'm
just
like
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my law in it like
no days off
on the road let's travel never looking
back